it was just amazing the most unselfish
people i've ever met in my life
all the things are wrong with this
system i don't know why you point your
anger
for it at them
am i five i knew this guy was dangerous
they've all got put on the runs and and
i will never be able to process it
john crilley and gareth evans are still
haunted by the events on london bridge
18 months ago the two ex-offenders
were guests at the learning together
rehabilitation seminar
inside fishmonger's hall as was
terrorist uzman khan
pictured here sitting next to one of his
victims
saskia jones a volunteer at the event
jack merritt one of the organizers was
another of khan's victims
in various images usman khan can be seen
inside the venue
mixing with others and wearing a heavy
coat to conceal
his fake suicide vest at one point
just before the attack he disappeared
into the toilets to tape knives to his
hands
it was down to ordinary people like john
and gareth
picking up anything they could find in
john's case a
fire extinguisher to fight off khan
pushing him out onto london bridge
he just all put together very lucky i
just raid him in the face with the thing
the knife hit his hose you see it's
based on the gold evil way
even though they managed to tackle khan
as armed police arrived
he was still wearing a very real looking
fake suicide burst
i'm shouting for him to shoot him i'm
telling him to shoot him
because he's just killed people then
obviously he's got the belt
so i just said i'm shouting there to
shoot him through it
within seconds susman khan is shot dead
but the inquest heard of multiple missed
opportunities to share intelligence
and properly supervise can in the
community
which the jury concluded contributed to
the deaths of saskia and jack
this inquest has answered many of our
questions about how jack came to be
killed
it's clear to us that the arrangements
put in place for managing usman khan
after his release from prison in 2019
were not fit for purpose
jack believed in the work he was doing
with prisoners through learning together
he saw firsthand the transformative
effect it had on the lives
of prisoners and students alike saskia
jones uncle expressed their family's
anger
at the organizers of the learning
together event
for failing to consider the potential
risks of such an event
attended by a convicted terrorist
it could be said that their
single-minded view of the rehabilitation
of offenders
using usman khan in our view as a poster
boy
for their program significantly clouded
their judgment
it seems there was no intent on their
part to listen or take notice
of what they were dealing with in
working with such a high risk
individual the uk's most senior
counter-terrorism officer
apologized for the failings and promised
changes
are being made that we are making these
changes after this attack
will i suspect be of little or no
comfort to jack and sassy's family
the fact that as the jury determined
there were emissions or failures in the
management of the attacker
and in the sharing of information and
guidance by the agencies responsible
is simply unacceptable and i'm so deeply
sorry we weren't better than this in
november 2019.
the ultimate blame of course lies in the
actions of one man
who ended the lives of two young people
dedicated to making a difference
gareth and john are still traumatized
and angry
john had the official failings gareth by
saskia's last moments
as he tried to offer what comfort he
could i'm never going to be able to
process reading them transcripts
the amount of times they've dropped the
ball i sort of knew
she was in trouble so i just tried to
talk to her and sort of
make sure she felt okay
i hope it makes some sort of difference
i hope it made some difference to her